fair warning today Siri will completely
alter the way you watch movies 3 through
7 part 2 otherwise known as 8 for any
sane human of the Harry Potter series if
you want to preserve the memories of
those go binge watch them now because
after today you will never look at the
battle between these two wizards the
same way again your childhood have been
warned hello internet welcome to film
theory the show where I was going to do
an episode on fantastic beasts but
frankly the more I looked into that
movie the more I just wanted to go back
and talk about some good old-fashioned
Harry Potter you know that feel when you
got a scamander and you just want a
little bit more Longbottom you know what
I mean you know what I mean you know
what I mean the quite a way and coming
back through the old Potter lore to
piece together the secrets of magical
beasts which will eventually become a
theory don't get your knickers in a
twist I discovered something that
literally changed everything I thought I
knew about everyone's favorite boy who
lived and no it's not something that's
an obvious part of the stories lore at
least I don't think so in a weird way
Harry should be thanking Voldemort
otherwise he would have just been well
Neville
then again that never one surprised me
too when I put all the pieces together
but apparently was old news to a bunch
of the Potterheads hey okay I'm sorry
I'm not the type of person who remembers
for memory what the Dursleys were eating
for breakfast on the morning that Harry
was invited to the Quidditch World Cup
whose grapefruit right I think was
grapefruit that's my answer grapefruit
let me know in the comments if I'm right
anyway this serie hinges on an ancient
form of magic number magic otherwise
known as math man can you think about
how much more excited everyone would be
to have their fifth theory class be
number magic instead of math math real
talk you got yourself a branding problem
and heck no under Harry encode in figure
this one out themselves
since number magic isn't even the
subject that they're taught but don't
you worry because I've got you covered
so hop on those fireballs cuz away we go
for this theory we get to go back way
back
Harry Potter part six long before Harry
pulled the ultimate fanboy move and
named his kid Albus Severus Potter we
got this scene where we see Tom Riddle
otherwise known as pre Voldemort
learning about splitting his soul using
dark magic cool sounds funny okay it's
the first time that we hear Tom Riddle
specifically mentioned Horcruxes which
we know he later uses to divide up his
soul into neat little slices of soul pie
and shove him into pretty much anything
he can get his hands on from books to
cups to snakes snakes not Snape no real
talk how awesome would it be to have
snakes on a plane get these models cool
snaps off my mother laid semi old
Jackson must have failed potions oh and
by the way this joke in fond memory of
Alan Rickman you are certainly mr. note
of sadness back to the theory as
Slughorn mentions in the scene Horcrux
talk is no laughing matter this is very
dark stuff there does he jump says
probably what we're all thinking like
the cheeky little scamp that he is but
in all seriousness how does this work
because if you really stop to think
about it there are some pretty severe
implications to this whole Horcrux
business that goes unexplored in the
books and movies so before we go there
let me remind you of the mechanics of
splitting your soul this one is for all
of us who aren't hardcore enough to have
you on their way through the Deathly
Hallows Part 1 15 times let's be honest
here for a second we can all agree right
that Ron being gifted and brought back
by a deluminator is a pretty darn goofy
moment right my only one who thinks that
still because seriously the thing just
tastes light away from things it doesn't
also have a magical teleportation device
in it that's just random you must be JK
JK anyway a Horcrux is an object that
contains or hides part of someone's soul
thus allowing them to survive should
someone kill their original body it's
like a bank but instead of money you
store soul just like a real bank and
you've seen those interest rates lately
seriously less than 1% what are you
doing economy anyway in the scene we saw
before Slughorn dishes up some really
handy exposition by telling us that to
create a Horcrux we have to commit a
murder and somehow use the life energy
transferred during that murder to split
your own soul in half and sort of rip
part of it out of your body and cram it
into the nearest object of your choice
present
something with a little staying power
and not that weak old block of cheese in
the back ear fridge no I will admit that
things been in there for a while and at
this point I ain't touching it so
perhaps that she is even mental for that
soul anyway based on the info from the
books of the movies the actual mechanics
of soul cutting and soul transferring
are a bit hazy it's not like we're
writing an eHow page on the subject we
get the general point that when you
create a Horcrux you're splitting your
soul in half between your body and an
object and that tells us everything we
need for today's theory
so Tom Riddle and Slughorn talk about
splitting the soul into seven pieces but
we all assume that at seven equal pieces
it is most definitely not every time
Voldemort splits his soul in half he
only leaves half of his remaining soul
in his own body then the next time he
creates a Horcrux it splits in half
again over and over so what does that
mean well let's walk through some
history that must not be named to see
how it all plays out he starts in 1943
with one whole soul this conversation
with Slughorn happens after the school
year starts in 1943 when tom is 16 years
old
in the chamber of secrets we learned
that Tom Riddle puts his 16 year old
soul into his diary thus creating the
first fork rock to create this Horcrux
he kills Moaning Myrtle which we also
confirm when she describes her killer as
a boy speaking a strange language but he
can be funny a kind of made-up exactly
Sinese pay you with water Horcrux lady
you must need a rhinoplasty is down to
50 percent of a soul with the other 50%
locked into the diary at this point we
know that the Diary is the Horcrux that
contains the largest percentage of
Voldemort's after that the creation of
each Horcrux is supposedly tied to a
major murder committed by Tom that least
according to JK Rowling in a rule that
will see her break-in just under 45
seconds now when Tom kills his father
Tom Riddle senior he creates the Marvolo
gaunt ring Horcrux which we see on his
finger in the scene with Slughorn this
is around the time of him creating the
diary also when he's either 16 or 17 and
since we're taking half the soul
Voldemort has remaining this means that
the gaunt ring has 25% Tom and Tom
himself is down to 25% and with his
prospects rapidly falling next he kills
Hepzibah Hepzibah I don't know how to
say your name Hepzibah but I'm gonna say
it that way because it's fun to say next
he kills Hepzibah Smith in 1945 followed
by a random muddle
like I said JK breaking her own rule
anyway these two characters aren't
really in the movies but were confirmed
in a web interview with JK Rowling in
2007 Tom bumps the bolt off and splits
his soul into the hufflepuff's cup that
we see in Goblet of Fire and the
Slytherin locket that shows up at the
Sirius Black estate so these were cruxes
have 12.5% soul and 6.25% soul with Tom
himself being down to 6.25% if you think
about what that means it's actually not
surprising that as he rises to power you
see them start to physically change and
responds to a soul being drained if you
can lose over 95% of your soul and only
really be missing some skin pigment your
hair and your nose that's not such a bad
trade-off for immortality all things
considered I'm just saying anyway the
next tour crosses in 1956 the ravenclaw
diadem we don't Baltimore chose back up
at Hogwarts at this point to ask
Dumbledore to become the Defense Against
the Dark Arts teacher which Dumbledore
turns them down
or after that Voldemort get this curses
the position and everyone who holds it
from then on hence the reason why every
year there's a new teacher in the
position I honestly didn't know this
until reading up on all the lore bits on
the Pottermore site it's been insane
Voldemort is like the sorest loser ever
and it's worth mentioning that this is
probably Voldemort's most effective
spell on the entire series
anyway JK Rowling has also confirmed in
several interviews that Voldemort cursed
the position and the curse wasn't broken
until he died and since it was in the
neighborhood anyway he had the diadem
Horcrux in the Room of Requirement which
is why what he says about it in the book
was ridiculously easy to find here's a
bright idea let me hide this item in a
room that if someone is required to kill
me well make sure it shows up right in
time for that person what an excellent
hiding spot again I suppose he required
that the room needed to be hidden so he
wouldn't die so really we just have the
Room of Requirement playing favorites
now I see of course u2 or choosing team
Harry
anyway short story even shorter if
Malfoy hadn't shown up the whole thing
would have taken like three minutes but
I digress what's important here is that
by age 30 Voldemort soul is down to
3.125% of his original soul and despite
talking about this grand plan to split
his soul into seven pieces just
absolutely suck it counting because he
actually quits at six five items and his
original soul way to do a job only 850
seven hundredths of the way voldie
because yeah at that point baltimore
takes a little siesta for about 30 years
I don't know maybe is afraid of more
appendages falling off so there's no
other Horcrux creation until 1981 that's
the moment when Voldemort attacks Harry
Potter
that's not even intentional Horcrux
creation I don't think this guy was ever
going to get to seven by the way just as
a side note anyone else realized that
Voldemort is 54 when he attacks Harry I
always just assumed that he was in like
his 30s and that is still decades before
the book he is literally 70 when we see
him returning to power that
crazy people give the guy a hard time
for looking as rough as he does come on
if I'm looking like that when I'm 70
then I must have had some plastic
surgery done because he's really missing
key features of his face also worth
mentioning in real life Harry Potter
would be almost 40 makes me feel sad and
old regardless we all know the story
when Harry Potter and Voldemort meet
Voldemort spells rebounds and he
inadvertently splits his soul again
making Harry the unintentional Horcrux
now there's some debate about the actual
Horcrux enos of Harry but in a web
interview with JK Rowling on the leaky
cauldron site she directly confirms that
Harry Potter is indeed the last
unintentional Horcrux so for this
episode I'm with her the important part
here is that when the attack happened
Voldemort's soul split again his body
basically vaporizes and turns that
remaining 1.5625 percent of soul into
some kind of weird wafting spirit that
later attaches to the back of Professor
Quirrell head like some sort of face
leech this also means that we pinpointed
exactly how much Voldemort is in Harry
just over 1.5 percent maybe that's what
Harry's car really is just a little full
schmutz on his forehead got a little
something just lick your thumb and
something right there that uh just says
you don't have a mother I have to do it
for you oh that hurt well just tell us
when the Harry Potter series starts well
first the whole Potter series is
predicated on a 1.5% soul blob which
does seem to take a little bit away from
the gravitas of this series it also
tells us that when Harry's deferring
Horcruxes some of them matter a whole
lot more than others the very first one
that Harry destroys is actually the
biggest deal because it contains
literally half of Voldemort half 50%
more than any other Horcrux and way more
than Voldemort himself at the end of the
series so in reality by the end of book
2 Voldemort is mathematically mostly
then from there the Horcruxes go on to
be destroyed and pretty much the same
order that they were created effectively
knocking out ninety six point eight
seven five percent of Baltimore's soul
before the final movie even begin
alright but I hear you remembering your
Harry Potter movie trivia and you all
see what I'm leaving out here it's not
the elephant in
it's the snake and if your Potter right
knows that Nagini is also a Horcrux in
the series but one that I haven't
mentioned yet at all well here's why the
Guinea was created in 1994 13 years
after his run-in with Harry Potter
during Harry's fourth year Nagini
becomes Voldemort last attempt to split
his soul into even more tiny little
fulcrum but what this means for the
series is the really fascinating part
because at this point with the creation
of the final Horcrux Voldemort sole
splits one final time leaving him with
only 0.78% less than 1% of his original
soul meaning that Nagini has the other
0.78% with so little soul left it's no
wonder that boldi can't effectively use
the Elder Wand at the end of the series
yeah yeah I know that the actual
explanation given in the movies is about
disarming the elder one from other
Wizards but that is a whole nother
episode unto itself my friends what's
even more shocking about this reveal is
that it means that Harry Potter himself
starting in the fourth movie and through
to the end series is more Voldemort than
bull de Bourg in fact he's literally
twice the Voldemort Voldemort is from
the fourth movie on where Tommy riddle
is that point 78% soul Harry from his
birth is rockin out at one point five
percent Voldemort and when you stop to
think about it that way the last battles
of this series are really anticlimactic
they are literally battling over a
villain with a health bar of less than
1% in this epic battle for Hogwarts the
grand evil wizard is just a fraction of
a fraction of a fraction so there you
have it definitive mathematical proof
supported by the author and the lore
that Harry Potter is more Voldemort than
the actual Voldemort in the Harry Potter
series they should look at them a bit
differently huh every time you see Harry
on screen you're literally looking at
the largest percent of Dark Lord walking
around in the whole series oh yeah and
if you want one final thing that will
completely ruin the way that you look at
Harry Potter from here on out Daniel
Radcliffe starred in the Broadway
production of Equus in which he rides
horses
is around naked so um have fun google
image searching that one put away your
wand Harry put it away but hey that's
just a theory
Oh film theory and guts
Accio subscribe button and remember it's
called subscribe uh and not subscribe so
please perform some magic of your own
and click that subscribe button like I
mentioned with fantastic beasts being a
new series you can bet series or on
their way about that one and if
subscribing ain't your thing well then
do me a favor click on your favorite
character Harry Ron or Hermione consider
this the super amazing end card
tournament she was whichever one I'm
just curious which one is your favorite
Hermione definitely mine I mean she's
got a great brain on her just saying so
please click subscribe if you haven't
make sure you cast your vote on your
favorite character and now if you'll
excuse me I have a new theory to work on
I'll see you next week with something
that's a bit more sinister and blonde
[Music]